hups was ist jetzt so was ist test ein mikrofon spackt rum wartet mal was ist
hier los assist ja schon viel besser exzellent wollen mich ein fünf spieler
leute ich muss noch mal schön dass ihr da seid ich muss aber ganz kurz aus
klopinkeln da bin ich gleich am start hallo da bin ich ich musste noch mal
kurz aflo razor danke für den sub wir gucken uns ein paar neue job angebote
an also nicht für mich aber so allgemein was es neues gibt gibt erlaufen neues
und wenn ihr irgendwas habt was wir uns im stream angucken sollen und wo ich
vielleicht mal meinen senf zu geben soll dann nur her damit und wir nicht ich
will es vor über 14 tagen haben wir uns das schon im stream angeguckt und es
gibt immer noch leute die kommen in den stream sagen max
hast du schon das stellenangebot mit windows 3l von der deutschen bahn gesehen
also ja vor fast drei wochen schon ja aber wenn ihr irgendwas habt wo ich
meinen senf zu geben soll sagt bescheid was denn jetzt irgendeine message von
der arbeit hey ich habe heute nicht keine bereitschaft und nichts was ist
das habe ich gar nicht gesehen irgendwelche wartungsarbeiten von mir
haben anscheinend was kaputt gemacht vorhin allerdings nicht keinerlei live
umgebung nur tests nur testing systeme
ja gut alle die haben drei stunden gebraucht hat darauf zu reagieren da war
ich schon weg da kann es nicht so wichtig sein wenn man also ich habe
vorher ein ticket bei uns aufgemacht hat gesagt hier bitte diesen endjob auf den
und den system ausführen also was habe ich gemacht ein simple job auf den
system ausgeführt bei zwei system gab es einen nichtssagenden sql fehler hier
habe ich ihm geschickt und drei stunden später anscheinend haben sie darauf
geantwortet durch das abbrechen des systemes haben sie darauf geantwortet durch das abbrechen des systemes haben sie darauf geantwortet durch das abbrechen
bei dem sql fehler läuft jetzt im dienst nicht mehr ob ich hier neu starten kann
das war irgendwie halb fünf da war ich schon längst nicht mehr da jetzt so
wichtig kann es nicht sein wenn es über drei stunden dauert bis heiter drauf
reagierte die hier ist ultra funny eine der schlimmsten firmen in dieser region
was ist denn azubi jo habe ich ja noch nie gehört
azubi was sich alles gibt warum ist es denn wenigstens nicht dazu azube punkt
io oder so
ich muss wieder nach frankfurt ins office fahren
da bin ich immer übelst im arsch danach ist unglaublich man macht quasi noch
weniger an dem tag wie normal aber allein schon durch das bisschen früher
aufstehen das hin und zurückfahren mit der bahn was soll eigentlich ganz gut
geklappt und einfach das rumsitzen im büro anstatt sein
das macht müde unglaublich ich weiß einfach was liegt weiß ich ob es dazu
vielleicht schon irgendwelche untersuchung oder so gibt links in jobs
view it spezialist wir gucken uns erst mal das hier an irgendjemand hat gesagt
lustig und schlimmste und schlimmste firma in der region weil kann ich jetzt
nicht beurteilen ich gebe nur wieder was der chat gesagt
hat es ist nicht meine einschätzung also könnte von absehen mich zu verraten
verklagen.
So, also, was haben wir denn
hier wieder? Ein A, das ist eine
guck mal, zur Abwechslung
eine Azubi
Stellenausschreibung.
So, das ist
nicht Azubio. Ach doch, das ist Azubio.
Ich hab das andere
aufgemacht. Okay, also,
was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Ausbildung Fachinformatiker.
Also,
also, entweder
schreibt man Fachinformatiker
für Systemintegration.
Meinetwegen auch Fachinformatiker
Sternchen innen. Aber
Fachinformatiker Sternchen
ist ja irgendwie
sehr unsinnig, oder?
Wildcard Fachinformatiker.
Wie ist da eigentlich das neutrale Wort
für Fachinformatikerinde?
Oder so?
Du findest es gut besser als innen?
Man könnte mal das Sternchen einfach weglassen.
Ja,
weißt du, wie man das noch besser lesen könnte?
Ohne Sternchen. Also, wenn man es nicht
schreibt, dann sollte man es einfach weglassen.
Was ich persönlich ja für vollkommen
ausreichend halte.
Jetzt kommen die Leute gleich wieder.
Ja, ja, war ja klar.
Okay, also, was, was,
wer ist das denn überhaupt? Wer bietet hier was an?
New Yorker.
Das ist irgendein
Jeansladen oder sowas, gell?
Leute, das ist noch, Max,
Max, es ist noch schlimmer.
Es ist noch viel schlimmer.
Ich bin
ein weißer,
alter,
heterosex, also, hast du ja, hast du ja schon,
hast du ja schon, hab ich vergessen.
Ein weißer, alter,
heterosexueller,
omnivorer Mann.
Das ist so ziemlich die, die,
die schlimmste Kombination, die du
heutzutage haben kannst.
Omnivore heißt Allesfresser.
Also nicht vegan.
Das ist, also, das ist, mehr geht nicht.
Deutsch auch noch.
Fuck, Alter.
Ja, es ist, dann ist es vorbei.
Also im Prinzip.
Ich gehöre wahrscheinlich zur großen Mehrheit.
Jetzt vorbei.
Alter, was ist mit meinem Mikrofon heute los, Mann?
The fuck? Was ist das?
Moment.
Das spackt rum. Mir ist vorhin, ist vorhin die Verlängerung runtergefallen.
Ich hoffe, das hat sich jetzt gefixt.
Okay, also, was, was wollen wir denn hier?
Dress for the moment.
Ah ja, okay.
Okay.
Dress for the moment ist mehr als nur ein Song.
New Yorker macht Mode für echte Momente.
Wir suchen Mitarbeiter.
Die, die finden dieses Sternchen.
Alter, mein, Alter, fuckt mich gerade mein Headset ab.
Was ist denn das?
Moment, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht.
Ist das vielleicht hier vorne?
Vielleicht liegt es da dran?
Nee, da liegt es nicht dran.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich muss mal entwirren.
Ja, so, jetzt, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, der Mist, der tut jetzt, ey.
Das ist so richtig alte Schrott.
Ich habe ein richtig gutes Headset, ein richtig gutes Autointerface, aber die Verlängerung ist absoluter Schrott.
Mein Headset hört sich auch übelst kacke an mit der Verlängerung, aber es ist halt eine Verlängerung.
Da wird es angenehmer.
Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Mut zur Innovation, bla bla bla bla.
Du bist in deinem Umfeld der erste Ansprechpartner, wenn es um PC-Komponente in der Hand vergeht.
Du möchtest eher gute...
Als Fisi ist das ja durchaus so im Bereich des Möglichen, ja.
Du möchtest...
Das sind...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das sind nicht meine Kopfhörer.
Das ist die Verlängerung.
Und du wirst den Unterschied hören, wenn ich umstöpsele, aber da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock, weil ich dann keine Verlängerung mehr dazwischen habe.
Du möchtest Systeme zu funktionieren, Netzwerken vernetzen, naja, okay, bla bla bla.
Also, was haben wir denn?
Das ist die Ausbildung, dreijährige duale Ausbildung, ja gut, also 0815 Standardgramm.
Nun, das läuft...
Was soll es auch sonst sein, ja?
Übrigens, mich hat letztens die IHK angerufen.
Da habe ich schon gedacht, was ist denn jetzt los?
Und wisst ihr, was die IHK von mir wollte?
Die wollte...
Moment, ich sag's euch.
Hier.
Hier ist es.
Ausbildung revoked.
Nein.
Wollten sie nicht.
Die Industrie- und Handelskammer hat mir geschrieben.
Und zwar...
IHK Vollversammlungswahl 2024.
Ihre Wahlunterlagen.
Und als wäre das noch nicht genug...
Ich habe den Kram ehrlich gesagt in die Ecke geschmissen und wollte den ja aufmachen.
Und als wäre der Kram noch nicht genug...
Hat mich dann auch noch eine von der IHK angerufen.
Und gefragt, ob ich die Wahlunterlagen bekommen habe.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, die habe ich bekommen.
Aber ich habe noch nicht reingeguckt.
Ja, sie führen mal eine Befragung durch, ob man dann an dieser Wahl teilnehmen möchte.
Da musste ich ihr versprechen, dass sie Ruhe gegeben hat.
Ich gucke es mir an.
Ich habe es mir angeguckt, sonst hätte ich es gar nicht ausgepackt.
Ich habe es mir angeguckt und habe festgestellt, eigentlich geht es mir am Arsch vorbei.
Ich bin in der Mitte.
Ich lade eh nur drin, weil ich muss, nicht weil ich will.
Okay, aber weiter.
Weiter, weiter.
Warum musst du da sein?
Wieso? Wo muss ich sein?
Achso, ja, weil das Pflicht ist, anscheinend.
Wenn du Gewerbe anmeldest, musst du zur IHK.
Oder hast du gelitten?
Ja.
Geklaut, kannst dich freuen drauf.
Also, dreijährige duale Ausbildung.
Du durchläufst in mehrmonatigen Abteilungseinsätzen in verschiedene Bereiche.
IT wie Infrastructure, Workplace und IT.
Okay, das ist normal, das machen ganz viele, also, aber so nahezu alle Unternehmen, in denen ich mal tätig war, machen das so, dass die Azubis rumgeschleust werden durch verschiedene Abteilungen.
Ich hatte Glück, ich finde dieses System übrigens auch nicht gut, meiner Meinung nach, aber das machen total viele.
Ich hatte das Glück, bei mir war das nicht so, weil...
Ich war zwar, ich habe zwar auch eine Ausbildung in einer Firma gemacht, die das normalerweise so macht, aber ich war am Standort Frankfurt und im Standort Frankfurt gab es einen Kunde und für den hat man den ganzen Tag gearbeitet.
Das heißt, ich war immer bei den gleichen Leuten, hat mir für die gleichen Leute gearbeitet und dementsprechend war ich auch immer im Rechenzentrumbetrieb und Linux-Administration am Start.
Das ist im Prinzip ja auch genau das, was ich vorhatte zu machen und dementsprechend finde ich...
Ich mag das nicht so sehr, es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, mal so maximal das erste Jahr die Leute ein bisschen rumgucken zu lassen, was ihnen gefällt, aber dann sollte man sich die Azubis aussuchen lassen, sofern der jeweilige Bereich Leute haben, die da...
Also, man sollte sich den Azubi aussuchen lassen, wo er hin will.
Natürlich nur, wenn dann der Bereich auch sagt, ja, wir wollen den Azubi aussuchen.
Also, wenn der Azubi sagt, ja, wir wollen den Azubi haben, das macht ja keinen Sinn, wenn der Azubi sagen würde, ah, ich würde jetzt gerne hier in die App-Entwicklung oder so, also nein, da fieße ich eher nicht, aber sagen wir mal, ich würde gerne in die iOS-App-Entwicklung und das Team, was iOS-App-Entwicklung macht, sagt, boah, Alter, geh mir mit dem Typ weg, den kann ich nicht ab.
Das ist natürlich Blödsinn.
In der Regel wollen die ja beide dann.
Das finde ich sinnig.
Also, zwei Jahre, finde ich, ist viel zu lang.
Überleg mal, wenn du zwei Jahre lang nichts richtig lernst in deiner Ausbildung, was im Endeffekt so ist.
Wenn du nichts machst, außer alle paar Wochen Teams wechseln, dann hast du quasi zwei Drittel der Ausbildungszeit verschenkt.
Also, ich finde das nicht sinnvoll.
Das erste Jahr, meinetwegen, aber die letzten zwei Jahre müssen Hardcore-Know-How-Aufbau sein.
Was willst du denn sonst machen, wenn du fertig gelernt hast?
Sehe ich zumindest so.
Okay, lasst uns das mal kurz durchscrollen.
Berufsschule.
Ja, gut, ist halt in der Ausbildung so.
Der wöchentliche Berufsschulunterricht findet an der Otto B.
Nann, Bann, was?
Otto-Bennemann-Schule.
Warum wechseln die die Schule zwischendurch?
Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt mal kurz angucken.
Raunschweig.
Was hat die für Bewertungen?
Leute, Berufsschule haben immer schlechte Bewertungen.
Oh.
Ich meine, immer noch besser als Frankfurt-Werner-von-Siemens-Schule.
Mit den besten Fotos dabei.
Und danach, im dritten Jahr, gibt es die Heinrich-Dings.
Okay, okay.
Das ist deine Schule, okay.
Die ist so neu, die hat gar keine Bewertung anscheinend.
Wie Google immer weiter guesst, wo ich sein könnte.
Aber man hat jetzt schon alle Hanauer Postleitzahlen und Stadtteile durch, wo ich angeblich bin.
Am besten finde ich immer noch Google Maps, wenn ich mal wieder mitten im Main wohne.
Okay, die kenne ich nicht.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Google kennt die nicht.
Ich kenne die auch nicht.
Naja, alles klar.
Tätigkeit.
Die Vernetzung von bla bla bla bla.
Langweilig.
Ist Standard.
Wie als Hubi-Ausbildung.
Öh, was ist das?
Moment, ist nicht Standard.
Ich habe mich verguckt.
Ich nehme alles zurück.
Ich habe nicht weiter gelesen.
Ich kack noob.
Die Vernetzung von Hard- und Software-Komponenten zu funktionieren.
IT-System sowie die Bearbeitung von Service-Requests.
Boah, First-Level-Support.
Nicht zwangsläufig.
First-Level-Support muss nicht First-Level-Support sein.
Das kann jeglicher Level von Support sein.
Aber ich habe den doofen Eindruck, dass das nicht so ist.
Dass du wahrscheinlich dort auch im First-Level-Support landest.
Und alle Leute, die für mich gerne First-Level-Support machen, die sind eh nicht ganz normal.
Haben wir irgendwelche First-Level-Supporter bei uns hier gerade im Chat?
Macht ihr das, weil ihr müsst oder weil ihr wollt?
Vielleicht haben wir auch Glück und wir haben keine.
Du bist First-, Second- und Third-Level.
Ja, das meine ich nicht.
Ich meine wirklich jemand, der so Hotline-mäßig First-Level-Support macht.
Ja, Endanwender-Kontakt ist wirklich alles.
Allerschlimmste.
Ja, ja, das gebe ich.
Ja, das kann ich auch vollziehen.
Also, ich habe ja ein paar Sachen mitgekriegt.
Beim letzten Arbeitgeber habe ich ja in der Nähe gesessen von unserem Support.
Ich habe da ein paar Sachen mitgekriegt.
Das war so ein großes, großes, ein ziemlich großes Großraumbüro.
Das war das modernste quasi, das modernste Büro, was es da gab.
Da hatten sie einen extra Architekt da, der das designt hat und was auch immer.
Zumindest, ich saß da auch in dem gleichen...
...Büro und da habe ich ein paar Sachen mitgekriegt.
Das ist so für einen Arsch, Alter, im Support zu arbeiten.
Und das war wohlgemerkt nicht mal 0815 First-Level-Endkunden-Support,
sondern es war interner, noch nicht mal Support.
Das war eigentlich internes so Operation-Center oder wie auch immer man sowas nennt,
wo Systeme überwacht wurden und Störungen eskaliert wurden und sowas.
Aber wo halt auch Leute angerufen haben, ah hier, wenn ich da klicke, dann geht es nicht richtig und so.
Das, was da dabei, was da für Leute dabei waren teilweise, ist so nervig, ja.
Okay, das überzeugt uns.
Ein Schulabschluss, das würde mich auch überzeugen.
Ah, du hast einen guten Realschulabschluss, ein Fachhochschul- oder Allgemeine Hochschulreife.
Du hast einen guten Realschulabschluss.
Na, da weiß ich nicht, ob ich da drunter gefallen wäre, ob die mich genommen hätte.
Ich meine, ich habe nicht den schlechten, möglichsteren Realschulabschluss,
aber ich bin auch weit davon entfernt, den besten zu haben.
Ach so, deswegen wechseln die da, verstehe.
Sprachkenntnisse, du bist in der Förderung, ich bin im Twitch-Chat, das ist noch mal eine Nummer härter.
B2 Deutschkenntnisse sowie B1 Englischkenntnisse, okay, da kann ich mir,
das sieht man, ich kann mir immer nicht merken, was das ist.
EDV-Kenntnisse mit Microsoft Office.
Siehst du mal, da sieht man mal wieder, dass das Kacknoobs sind.
Das heißt gar nicht mehr Microsoft Office.
Wer weiß, wie das jetzt korrekterweise heißt?
Das heißt nicht Microsoft Office mehr.
Sondern, nicht nur Office, auch nicht nur Office.
Es heißt Microsoft 365.
Also M365.
Gut, ich meine, es sei denn, es sei denn,
die haben noch Office 2012 oder so.
Es gibt Office 365, nee, die haben doch selbst ihre Webseite umbenannt.
Guck, hier, wenn du Office 365 eingibst, steht da Microsoft 365.
Also viel offensichtlicher geht es ja gar nicht mehr, oder?
Office, guck mal, Chat.
Office is now Microsoft 365.
Also Chat, da könnt ihr mir viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist, aber.
Warum sieht denn die Seite so kacke aus, wie bei einem Dark Theme wahrscheinlich?
Gut, wie dem auch sei, hat ja gar nichts mit dem zu tun, was er machen wollte.
Office 365 teilweise ohne Teams und ohne extra.
Aha.
So genau muss ich das bei Microsoft gar nicht.
Wissen, ich hoffe.
Heute gab es bei uns auf der Arbeit eine Anfrage,
warum wir keinen Virenscanner unter Linux benutzen.
Kein Witz, Leute.
Ich wollte den, ich wollte eigentlich,
habe ich mir so gedacht, ey,
sagst du denen jetzt, es gibt Windows Defender auch für Linux?
Aber da dachte ich mir so, ich will die Leute auf keine doofen Ideen bringen.
Sag lieber nix.
Sonst haben wir demnächst Windows Defender auf Linux-Kisten.
Ich habe das schon mal gesehen, dass Unternehmen das machen.
Ich habe schon mal in einer,
ich habe euch ja erzählt, ja, wie Windows Defender für Linux eingeführt wurde.
Ist das nicht bar für eine Anforderung?
Weiß ich nicht, aber du kannst davon ausgehen,
nachdem die bei uns so super genau sind,
an den Stellen, wo das Anforderung ist, haben wir das.
100 pro.
Die sind so super, super genau, was das angeht.
Das Ding heißt dann bestimmt auch noch Microsoft Defender.
Nein, Windows Defender für Linux heißt Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection.
Das hier.
Ist das.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so heißt.
Ach nee, anscheinend heißt es mittlerweile Microsoft Defender für Endpunkt.
Was ein Scheiß Name.
Was ein Scheiß Name, Alter.
Ist das ein Kack Name, Mann.
Microsoft Defender für Endpunkt.
Welcher?
Was ein Kack Name, Mann.
Eins zu eins aus dem Englischen.
Okay, Leute.
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint ist auch nicht besser.
Aber hier ATP Richtlinie.
Jetzt wird es aber Boomer im Chat hier, Leute.
Wobei man sagen muss, die Boomer sagen nicht kleinweich.
Die sagen Mini-Wolfen.
Weichwindow. Oh, das ist so
cringe, ey.
Ich weiß, ich bin auch vom Alter her
schon so, aber ich kann
mir, ich muss da immer echt,
da schüttelt es mich immer, wenn die mit
sowas ankommen.
Äh, die sagen, du hast recht,
die sagen winzig,
siehst du mal, ich kann das noch nicht mal richtig
nachmachen. Du meinst,
wenn schon, müsste man das komplett auf Deutsch
übersetzen? Wenn schon, müsste man
das komplett auf Deutsch übersetzen?
Also du meinst quasi sowas wie
ähm, Fenster
Verteidiger für Endpunkt
oder
fortschrittliche
Bedrohung,
na wobei, ohne Scheiß,
Advanced Threat
Protection, klingt
übersetzt gar nicht so, gar nicht so dumm.
So, fortgeschrittene Bedrohungs,
äh, fortgeschrittener
Bedrohungsschutz,
könnte man das nennen. Das klingt
gar nicht so kacke.
Da klingt
Microsoft Defender für Endpunkt
deutlich schlechter.
Ja, ich hab's falsch geschrieben, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ja.
Fensterverteidiger für Endpunkt.
Okay, wir sind etwas
abgeschwiffen jetzt.
Minimal.
Also du sollst Microsoft
Office Kenntnisse haben.
Mit Microsoft Office hast du
bereits gearbeitet und in deiner Freizeit
beschäftigst du dich gerne mit Hardware.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute
Beschreibung für
Voraussetzungen von, ähm,
Fachinformatiker-Azubis. Allerdings,
nur der letzte Teil.
Microsoft Office
fand ich früher schon kacke,
fand ich
vor der Ausbildung kacke, fand ich
während der Ausbildung kacke, find ich
nach der Ausbildung kacke und find ich heute
immer noch kacke. Also,
nee.
Aber, ja, das, das ist auf jeden Fall
was, wo ich denke, das sollte auf die meisten
Physis zutreffen. Softskills.
Sollte man haben. Okay, da bin ich schon mal weg.
Da bin ich schon mal raus. Könnte ich keine Ausbildung
machen bei denen. Die wollen Softskills.
Neben einem freundlichen
Auftreten zeichnet dich dein
analytisches
Denkvermögen sowie ein hohes Maß
an Teamfähigkeit aus.
Okay, ist es teamfähig, wenn ich
weiß, dass ich kein, dass ich
keinen Bock auf Team-Events
hab und nicht so tue,
als ob ich da Spaß dran hab, sondern
einfach nicht hingehe?
Ist ja auch irgendwie teamfähig, so.
Ne, also, man, man, man lügt den Leuten
nicht vor und sagt dann einfach, was ist.
Und die meisten verstehen das auch.
Die meisten verstehen das.
Also, seitdem ich mich echt da
persönlich dazu durchgerungen habe,
nichts mehr zu faken, wenn ich keinen Bock
mehr hab, muss ich sagen, fahr ich insgesamt
deutlich besser. Die Leute
nehmen einem das ganz, ganz selten mal krumm.
Machen halt vielleicht
irgendeinen Spruch, da kannst du sagen, nee, nee,
liegt nicht an euch, ich mag sowas nicht.
Die verstehen das dann oder denken so, jo, mach was
willst, mir doch egal.
Also, es ist viel angenehmer
für die Leute, die da hingehen und Bock drauf
haben, für mich, für alle.
Zu deinen Stärken zählen zudem
als Selbstständigen proaktive Arbeitsweise.
Wie soll denn ein Azubi
eine proaktive
Arbeitsweise haben, gerade
wenn er neu ist?
Dem musst du die Sachen zeigen und er muss
die lernen?
Also, das stell ich mir
als Azubi doch dann
sehr schwierig vor,
zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, oh, ich hab da gestern
ein Ticket gesehen, ich erweitere
heute schon mal den Speicherplatz, weil ich weiß,
dass das dann bald voll...
Ja, also...
Ich glaube, dass das so 0815 Sprüche
sind, die da immer reinschreiben.
Ich mein, proaktive Arbeitsweise heißt auf Deutsch
eigentlich nur, dass du etwas vorausschauend
arbeitest. Und ja, das kann man von einem Azubi
auch erwarten, aber das
klingt jetzt hier schon super advanced, aber
ich glaub, die meinen es gar nicht so.
Max, hier ist
was für dich. Ich mach das nicht im
Stream auf, weil man nicht weiß, was das ist.
Oh, also
das ist, glaub ich...
Wie heißt
dieses Subreddit?
Ich bin 50 und lustig? Oder ich bin 60
oder ich bin über 40
und lustig? Gibt es da so ein komisches
Subreddit für?
Das ist typisch... Oder Facebook
Boomer Humor. Da könnte
sowas... Ja.
Da könnte genau
sowas drin stehen.
Das ist so unlustig. Das ist so
komisch.
Warum ich hier...
Eine offene Unternehmenskultur...
Also ganz ehrlich, da gibt es jetzt
nichts Schlechtes über die Anzeige zu
sagen, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist ganz 0815.
Wir suchen eine Azubi-Stellenanzeige.
Die sind ja meistens nicht sonderlich
advanced.
Und ausgefallen.
Die Abteilung Ausbildung
Headquarters.
Wir starten dich während deiner Ausbildungszeit
mit einem eigenen...
Ach.
Ich kann ja nicht spekulieren, dass die
mich ausrüsten mit allem, was ich zum Arbeiten brauche.
Ach, deswegen haben die Sternchen,
weil da unten nochmal eine Erklärung kommt.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Na, reich wirst du als Azubi echt nett, gell?
Wobei ich sagen muss, es ist schon eine ganze Ecke
mehr, als ich damals verdient habe,
aber
es ist ja auch mittlerweile
alles deutlich teurer geworden.
Nicht nur die letzten paar Jahre besonders,
sondern halt auch die ganze Zeit dazwischen.
Es ist ja auch schon wieder...
Na ja, noch nicht ganz 20 Jahre her.
Nicht ganz, nicht ganz.
15, oder? Nee, warte mal.
16?
2007?
Ja.
Quickmuffs.
Nee, 17.
17.
Krass. Kommt mir gar nicht so lange vor.
Ha.
Du hättest noch einen Ausbildungsfilm für die Firma,
der ist wirklich cringe und lustig.
Ja, schick mal her.
Also, da kann ich jetzt
nichts schlechtes drüber sagen, Chat.
Also, da habe ich keine Ahnung,
wie gut und schlecht das ist.
Keine Ahnung, ist eine ganz normale Azubi-Stellanzeige.
Ups.
Bei der Stadt Wolfsburg.
Das ist bestimmt cringe, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich so viel cringe
gerade ertragen kann.
Mit Modem-Sound,
da weißt du schon Bescheid.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich heute gelesen habe?
Ich habe es nicht für möglich gehalten.
Aber Deutschland ist echt das Land,
der Faxer und der Dichter und Faxer.
Oder wie habe ich das letztens im Video gesagt?
Der Faxer und Denker
oder der Dichter und Faxer?
Ist auch egal.
Zumindest, es gibt jetzt eine Funktion
in der AOK,
glaube ich,
Krankenkasse-App.
Also, Smartphone-App
von der Krankenkasse.
Und zwar, die haben dort jetzt eine Funktion
Gesundheitskarte vergessen.
Und ratet mal, was passiert.
Wenn du das machst,
ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Also, man würde vielleicht denken,
dass man dann
die Karte irgendwie
auf dem Handy anzeigen lassen kann.
Ja?
Du kannst dir mit dieser Funktion
der Arztpraxis
deine Karte per Fax schicken lassen.
Ja? Ja, tatsächlich.
Das löst einen Fax aus, diese Funktion.
Ja!
Ja, Leute!
Ihr mögt es mir vielleicht nicht glauben,
aber es ist so.
Da wird ein Fax geschickt.
Wir sind im Arsch, ja?
Da wird ein Fax losgeschickt.
Kein Spaß.
Guckt nach, wenn ihr es mir nicht glaubt.
Ja, die haben total viel.
Ich meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass am Anfang von Corona
die Corona-Zahlen in Deutschland
ja immer ein bisschen verzögert waren,
weil die ganzen Sachen immer erst
verschickt werden mussten.
Es ging nicht anders.
Ähm,
Sekunde, Leute, ich muss mir mal,
ich sehe nämlich gerade, ich habe gar nichts zu trinken hier.
Ich hole mir mal kurz
ein Wasserglas.
So.
Ich bin wieder da.
Was haben wir denn hier als nächstes noch zu bieten?
IT-Spezialist
bei LinkedIn.
Let's go.
Warum ist das so hell?
Ein IT-Spezialist
Anwendungsbetreuung
Aviation
Also, äh, so
Luftfahrt
heißt das glaube ich übersetzt,
oder?
Ja, Luftfahrt.
Berlin Airport.
Ist das der, der so lange gebaut wurde?
Ja?
Also, da kann ich ja gar nichts zu sagen
zu der Branche.
Also, was macht man denn?
Also, du bist IT-Spezialist
für Anwendungsbetreuung, okay?
Strategische und technologische Weiterentwicklung
von IT-Anwendungen, Systeme und deren
Architektur inklusive IT-Standards.
Das ist auch so absolut global.
Ja, und was IT-Standards?
Welche Standards?
Alle, alle Standards.
Okay.
Für Aviation-Systeme.
Da gibt es sicherlich viele Standards.
Weil Luftfahrt
ist sicherlich eines der Gebiete, wo
noch mit am meisten
von allem, was es so gibt,
standardisiert ist.
Oder wenn es kein offizieller
Standard ist, dann zumindest
ein Standard in der Art, man hat sich da
halt mal drauf geeinigt. Irgendeiner hat mit
angefangen, alle anderen haben es übernommen.
So, Planung,
Realisierung, IT-Anwendung, Systeme, Analyse,
Beratung der Fachbereiche zur Abbildung
ihrer Geschäftsprozesse.
Das ist auch so ein
Universal-Ding.
Projektleitung
und Steuerung von
Projekten von IT-Anwendungen und Systemen.
Warum sucht ihr
keinen Projektmanager?
Also, bei einem
IT-Spezialist denke ich nicht unbedingt
an einen Projektleiter.
Überwachung und Steuerung von externen Partnern
von IT-Anwendungssystemen.
Das würde ich auch nicht unbedingt bei
dem sehen. Da gibt es dann
oftmals Provider-Manager oder sowas.
Aber das kann,
das passt zumindest noch halbwegs.
So ein bisschen in die Richtung.
Aber das eigentlich passt doch da gar nicht
dazu, oder?
Wahrscheinlich brauchen die einfach drei
Stellen und haben nur eine.
Abgeschlossenes
fachgebietsrelevantes
Fachhochschulstudium
oder vergleichbare
Kenntnisse in
Enterprise
Integration
Umgebung.
Zum Beispiel
WSO2
Enterprise
Integrator
AP Manager
Ich habe beim besten Willen
keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was ist das?
WSO2
Your Systems
United Efficiency
Quality is Destiny
What is Enterprise Integrator?
Der Enterprise
Service Bus.
Das ist so Enterprise, dass du beim Lesen nicht weißt,
was es ist. Oh guck mal, die haben
ein Projekt.
Moment, das Ding ist Open Source?
Das kann nicht sein.
Enterprise ist nie Open Source.
Oh.
Leute, wenn ihr diese Datei seht,
wenn ihr diese Datei seht,
in welcher Programmiersprache
ist das wohl programmiert?
Was könnte es wohl
sein?
Muss eigentlich Java sein.
Wofür auch die Projektstruktur
nicht?
Wo man nämlich schon gar nicht weiß,
wo man eigentlich reingucken soll.
Alter, wie viele Unterordner.
CSV Sample
Ah, obviously, alles klar.
Produkt I
Der Enterprise Integrator
Ok, also
lassen wir uns doch mal erklären,
was das eigentlich
macht, dieses Produkt.
WSO2
Enterprise Integrator
ist ein Open Source
ein
Open Source schnell
Cloud Native
skalierbare Integrationslösung
ähm
was zum
das
ist
welches der Kern ist von
WSO, ok, ich verstehe immer noch nicht
was, hä?
Open Source Fast Cloud Native
and Scalable Integrationslösung
Core of WSO2
Integration Agile Plattform
Das ist absolut nichtssagender
Satz
Was ist das denn jetzt?
It enables Enterprise Integration
Developers
Da fängt es ja schon an, was ist eine Enterprise Integration?
To build sophisticated
integration solutions
to achieve digital agility
Alter, wer hat diesen
Intro Satz geschrieben, Mann?
Und diesen Intro Text
Die ersten zwei Sätze
sind rum und ich habe absolut keinen blassen
Schimmer davon, was es eigentlich ist
Aber die sind sehr agil
habe ich auf jeden Fall schon festgestellt
Ok
Es ist ein sehr
ausgereiftes Integration
Product, was es schon seit 2005
gibt
Damals hieß es allerdings noch WSO2
ESB
Ja, und es ist weiterhin
die most sophisticated
and extensible Open Source Enterprise
Integration Solution
available. Ich glaube, die
setzen einfach drauf, dass man weiß, was Enterprise
Integration ist
Enterprise, das Problem an diesen zwei Wörtern
ist, dass sie sehr allgemeingültig sind
Ok
Ich habe wirklich
nicht den leisesten Schimmer
was das ist
Hat es jemand von euch gecheckt?
Was es ist?
Eine Hybrid Integration
Plattform
Aha, unterschiedliche Bereiche
einer kompletten Integration Story
Pfff
Das bräuchten wir hier auch teilweise
Eine komplette Integration Story
If you
What the fuck
Ist das
Ist das eine Message Queue?
Das ist so eine Art Message Queue, oder?
Das ist eine Art
Das ist so eine Art Message Queue
Wo du von verschiedenen Systemen
einliefern kannst und dann
von verschiedenen Systemen wahrscheinlich umwandeln
ein bisschen das Format in deinem anderen System wieder aus
Aha
Was ist eine Message Queue?
Ok
Ich versuch das mal so einfach wie
Wo war da hier die Frage?
Ich versuch das mal so einfach wie möglich zu erklären
was eine Message Queue ist
anhand eines Beispiels
Ok, stell dir vor
Du hast
einen Online Shop
und die Leute dort
können sich anmelden
für so einen
Weekly Angebots Newsletter
zum Beispiel
Da ist es jetzt ja so, dass das System
was die Leute sich anmelden
für die Newsletter
und das System was die E-Mails verschickt
meistens ja nicht das gleiche ist
So
und
E-Mails werden ja auch nicht synchron verschickt
und es ist auch nicht so
als müsste dein Shop warten
auf irgendwas mit weiteren
Bestellungen zu bearbeiten
bis die E-Mails verschickt sind
oder sowas
So, und was dann in der Regel passiert ist
die deine Shop Software
die weiß, die Verbindung zur Datenbank hat
und weiß wer dein Newsletter
abonniert hat
die schickt dann einen Auftrag los
so nach dem Motto
jetzt Newsletter verschicken
und jetzt muss ja irgendjemand
auf diese Nachricht
jetzt Newsletter verschicken reagieren
So, und dann läuft das meistens so
das wird in eine Message Queue gelegt
aus der Message Queue
holt es dann irgendein anderer Prozess
wieder raus oder irgendein
anderes Produkt wieder raus
erzeugt die E-Mails und verschickt die E-Mails
ja, das heißt deine Shop Software
muss nicht irgendwie darauf warten
dass diese E-Mails Prozessed sind
und deine Shop Software ist ja auch nicht
dafür zuständig irgendwie E-Mails zu verschicken
das ist quasi zum Asynchronen
abarbeiten von
Aufträgen, ein bisschen
was, kennst du die
Druckerwarteschlange von Windows
das ist ein bisschen wie die Druckerwarteschlange
nur für alle möglichen
Aufgaben, nicht nur für
Drucke
für Prince
was sagt denn
Wikipedia was eine Message Queue ist
sind Mailboxen
nein
das ist bescheuert
nein nein das stimmt nicht was da
also
das mit Mail war nur ein Beispiel
Message Queue hat nichts mit E-Mail zu tun
ja es gibt bei E-Mail
auch Message Queues, aber das habe ich damit nicht gemein
was ist
eine Nachrichtenwarteschlange, ok
PS erklärt uns das jetzt
eine Nachrichtenwarteschlange ist
eine Art der Kommunikation zwischen Services
die in bla bla bla
ich glaube man hat es verstanden
auch wenn ich das erklärt habe
ok wir sind hier stehen geblieben ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist
aber gut damit muss man sich auskennen
weiterer weiterer
weiteres Beispiel wo man
für Message Queue ist beispielsweise
stell dir vor
du möchtest einmal im Monat
irgendeinen Report generieren
mit deinen Shop umsetzen
so du hast aber ganz ganz
viele Kunden und das Report generieren
dauert 2 Stunden
es wäre ja blöd wenn deine Shop Software
in der Zwischenzeit hängt
und eigentlich muss das komplette Report
generieren und das
PDF erzeugen und sowas
das muss deine Shop Software auch nicht können
du hast einmal eine Software
die deine Reports schön generiert
und du hast deine Shop Software
die Shop Software schreibt den Auftrag
bitte Report generieren in die Message Queue
der andere Service der für das Report generieren
zuständig ist liest die aus der Message Queue
aus und fängt an asynchron den
Report zu generieren sowas zum Beispiel
ok
also damit soll man sich auskennen ich habe keine Ahnung
was das eigentlich ist
technisches Know How in Webservice
Methoden und API Design
macht Sinn
gute
Kenntnisse ich meine was auch immer
Webservice Methoden sein soll
ja
was sind Webservice Methoden
SOAP XML
REST würde ich jetzt
auch rein interpretieren
gute Kenntnisse im Linux sowie
Kenntnisse im Windows
warum sind die eigentlich immer so realitätsfern
es gibt keine
Leute die sich gut mit Linux
und Windows auskennen
und wenn es die gibt
dann haben die höchstwahrscheinlich
keinen Bock mehr auf Windows
es gibt Leute die haben früher viel
Windows gemacht
und kennen sich deswegen historisch noch ganz gut mit
Windows aus machen aber jetzt
eine ganze Weile Linux und sind jetzt darauf hängen geblieben
es ist nahezu
ausgeschlossen das du jemand findest mit
mit wirklich aktuellen
Linux Kenntnissen und wirklich aktuellen Windows Kenntnissen
in einer Person und die
arbeiten heute auf dem Mac wahrscheinlich
ja aber
und umgedreht passiert
das eigentlich so gut wie nie also
also was Chat mal
Frage an euch ja also ich kenne
einige Windows Leute die
früher viel Windows gemacht haben
dann irgendwann mit Linux angefangen haben
und jetzt eigentlich nur noch hauptsächlich Linux machen
was ich nicht kenne es ist
Windows äh Schwachsinn
ich muss ja dazu mal neu anfangen
was ich nicht kenne ist
ähm Linux Leute
die sich quasi ihr ganzes Leben
mit Linux beschäftigt haben
dann bisschen was in Windows machen müssen
und auf Windows hängen geblieben sind
das ist mir nicht bekannt
ich kenne das nur umgedreht
ist ja auch verständlich
weil wenn du einmal im Serverbereich
mit Linux gearbeitet hast
fragt dich Windows einfach nur Ultra ab
deswegen ist logisch
dass in die andere Richtung es funktioniert
aber nicht zurück
also ich habe auch Kenntnisse
im Windows Server Umfeld
ich kann mich da drauf einloggen
ich kann diesen komischen hässlichen
wie heißt dieses Ding bei Microsoft nochmal
dieser Server wisst ihr
das was am Anfang auch immer automatisch aufgeht
dieser Server Configuration Manager
wie heißt denn das Teil
dieses hässliche Ding kann ich aufmachen
und drei Sachen klicken
ja ok nice Windows Server
super krasse Kenntnisse
aber allein schon deswegen würde ich mich nicht drauf bewerben
weil es ja für mich aussieht als müsste ich Windows machen
da dreh ich ja durch
also mir gehen bürokratische Sachen schon auf den Keks
und und
ja es gibt genug Sachen die mir auf den Keks gehen
aber Windows administrieren ist so ein Ding
was für mich wirklich Kündigungsgrund ist
ohne Scheiß
also wenn jemand zu mir sagt Max
Windows sage ich ja gut
dann ohne mich
das würde ich
ich meine gut ich bin käuflich was das angeht
wenn einer sagt Max wir bezahlen dir
vier mal mehr im Jahr
vier bis fünf mal mehr im Jahr
du machst jetzt Windows
dann würde ich mir vielleicht mal kurzfristig überlegen
ob ich das nicht doch mache
aber das ist äußerst unrealistisch
dass die mir eine halbe Million plus
im Jahr bezahlen
um Windows zu machen
da muss der Fachgeist
da muss der Fachkräftemangel
da muss der Fachkräftemangel doch schon
ganz gut fortgeschritten sein
dass das der Fall ist
also sagen wir mal so
für eine halbe Million plus
im Jahr
würde ich Windows Administration machen
ok
aber das war es dann auch
also drunter muss da keiner ankommen
und das würde ich dann auch
wirklich nur ein paar Jahre machen
und dann nie wieder
wisst ihr was das dumme ist
wisst ihr was die Scheiße ist
selbst wenn die dir eine halbe Million
im Jahr bezahlen
bei dir kommen ja am Ende nur
250.000 Euro an
ich mein du bezahlst dann
nicht nur Spitzensteuersatz
sondern super mega Spitzensteuersatz
von keine Ahnung wieviel das ist
48% oder sowas
das sackt
ja nur 250k für Windows
ist mir zu wenig
das mach ich nicht dafür
weil wenn
also da bin ich
da habe ich eine so hohe Schmerzgrenze
die müssten mich so extrem
mit Geld zuscheißen
dass ich Windows machen würde
das wird keiner machen
wenn 500k ankommen würden
dann würde ich Windows
also
halbe Million nachdem ich Steuern bezahlt habe
dann würde ich Windows administrieren
ok sonst nicht
gut lange Rede kurzer Sinn
fragwürdig
hohes Interesse an den
an der Flughafenbranche sowie den speziellen
ok
gibt ja Leute die mögen das
gibt Leute die mögen Züge
gibt Leute die mögen Flugzeuge
gibt Leute die mögen Flughafen
gibt sicherlich Leute für die ist das ganz
wie gesagt wie die Faust aufs Auge passt
fachspezifische Englischkenntnisse
natürlich beste
Einsatzfähigkeit zur möglichen Bereitschaft
ja gut warum nicht gibt aber extra Kohle
wir bieten Einmalzahlung wie ein 13. Monatsgehalt
das ist
das ist zwar ein Benefit in dem Sinn
aber wenn es um die Verhandlung
des Jahresgehalts geht
muss sowas
ja natürlich schon eingerechnet sein
also es sei denn es ist auch mit
12 Monatsgeldern schon so gut das ich es machen würde
und da kommt nochmal ein 13es drauf ja das wäre auch ok
aber wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein
das heißt im Endeffekt ist es für mich dann auch wieder egal
mobiles Arbeiten
das ist nice
wobei ich mir ganz ehrlich vorstellen kann
Flughafenbetrieb sonstwie da musst du wahrscheinlich
das mal vor Ort sein
ein spannender Arbeitsplatz umfangreiche
Weiterbildungsmaßnahmen
ahja
also ganz im Ernst
es klingt gar nicht so mies
wie ich am Anfang dachte
nachdem ich das hier gesehen habe mit Projektleitung
ich glaube die ist einfach nur unglücklich geschrieben
die Stellenanzeige
es passt nicht wirklich zusammen dass sie einen IT Spezialist suchen
der gleichzeitig noch
also das hier
das kann ich mir noch irgendwie in dem Kontext vorstellen
dass du das mit übernimmst
quasi zu gucken
für unsere Software haben wir von
den und den Dienstleistern zusätzliche
Plugins
oder was auch immer eingekauft
oder dort wird extern was entwickelt das man da ein Auge drauf hat
das verstehe ich schon
aber
das da finde ich passt überhaupt nicht rein
Projektleitung von Projekten
du bist Anwendungsspezialist
oder IT Spezialist
Anwendungsbetreuung du bist kein
Projektmanager
also die wollen eigentlich zwei Leute die wollen einen IT Spezialist
für ihren Anwendungs
Betreuungskram
richtig passt
naja
und den Projektmanager
aber ich rate jetzt einfach mal
wie das ist
und zwar ich gehe davon aus dass IT Spezialist
bei denen halt eine interne Bezeichnung ist
und dort das normal ist
dass IT Spezialisten auch
zum größten Teil die Projektleitung übernehmen
das ist aber halt für uns als Außenstehende
nicht klar
Steinhardt danke für den Sub gar nicht gesehen
was stand heute auf dem Speiseplan
mexikanisch
hier ich war heute hier essen in Frankfurt
da war ich heute essen
allerdings habe ich nicht das gegessen
was man hier sieht
schaut gesund aus
naja
semi
gesund
das habe ich heute gefuttert
Pommes frites mit spicy Kram
also das hier sieht ja noch relativ gesund aus
da gebe ich euch recht das habe ich nicht gegessen
das habe ich heute gefuttert
ein Beef Burrito
so gesund sieht mein Zeug
nicht aus
haben die hier sowas
im Prinzip
habe ich
habe ich sowas hier heute gefuttert
man sieht es halt leider nicht
es ist im Prinzip eine Art Subway
Subway für mexikanischen Kram
so ein bisschen
sah das aus was ich heute gegessen habe
ja
für mexikanischen Kram
hat sich auch verschiedene Sachen drauf machen lassen
ok
Chat haben wir noch was
ach ja wir hatten auch noch einen Cringe
Cringe ok
Chat
also
ich muss mal kurz den Sound ausmachen
ich habe zu viele Fenster auf ich blick gerade immer durch
Chat ihr dürft jetzt selbst
entscheiden
dieser Clip wurde mir mit äußerst viel Cringe
angekündigt vom Twitch Chat
wollen wir den gucken
halten wir so viel Cringe aus
nicht das gleich Dice of Cringe angesagt ist
ok
auf gehts
die Stadt Wolfsburg sucht dich
als Fachangestellten
für Systemintegration
erst mal Modem Sound
ok das ist auf
auf absichtlich
quasi Cringe gemacht
das ist kein
zufälliger Cringe das ist auf
absichtlich Cringe gemacht
macht schon mal besser
da kommt jetzt auch der weiße Hase
was soll das
nein
folge dem Wolf
ach so ist ja die Stadt Wolfsburg
ist ja gut
ja
stimmt was nicht
du siehst irgendwie blasser aus als sonst
mein Computer hat
kennst du das Gefühl wenn du nicht weißt ob du noch schläfst
oder wach bist
kenn ich jeden Morgen vom ersten Kaffee
kann das sein dass du ein bisschen
mehr Abwechslung in deinem Leben brauchst
wie siehts aus
dann komm doch zur Stadt Wolfsburg
Lust mitzukommen
ich kann nicht ich muss noch
ja ok
warum nicht
Hi ich bin Simon ich bin Fachinformatiker
so schlecht ist es gar nicht gemacht
Systemintegration bei der Stadt Wolfsburg
Hi ich bin One ich bin dualer Student
bei der Stadt Wolfsburg
Informatik
wir kümmern uns im groben und ganzen darum
dass so ziemlich alle Leute die bei der Stadt arbeiten
arbeiten können
also wir kümmern uns um das ganze Equipment was sie brauchen
sei es ein Computer sei es ein Monitor
sei es Maustastatur Kopfhörer
kümmern uns darum dass das Internet läuft
dass die Leute miteinander finden
das haben die extra dahingestellt so nach dem Motto
ok wir brauchen irgendwas zum Filmen
also in der IT muss man schon im Team arbeiten können
ein kleiner Fehler kann große Auswirkungen
auch auf andere Kollegen haben
warum machen die HTML auf der Tafel
und PHP vor allem
auf der Tafel
deswegen sollte man schon kommunikativ sein
einfach nur für das Video oder
mit anderen Menschen arbeiten können
man muss eher Wolfsrudel sein
hahaha
dies ist deine Chance
schluckst du die rote Kapsel
bist du Teil des Wolfsrudels
und ich führe dich in die tiefsten Tiefen deiner neuen Ausbildung
so schlimm war das jetzt auch wieder nicht
wie angekündigt
das war doch im Bereich
wie soll man sagen
gut gemacht im Bereich der Möglichkeiten
gute Idee
ja
ich fand das gar nicht so schlimm
ich würde mich jetzt nicht unbedingt
deswegen bewerben
ich fand das nicht wild
übrigens Fun Fact
was ihr gerade am Anfang seht
die haben das gut gemacht mit diesem Grünton
ich meine die haben das mit irgendeinem Filter gemacht
aber wusstet ihr
dass der grüne Effekt in Matrix 1
ich weiß es nur von Matrix 1
also den einzigen Matrix Film den es gibt
den es sich lohnt zu gucken
wusstet ihr
dass der grüne Effekt in Matrix
nicht
mit einem Filter
gemacht wurde
sondern
dass sie wirklich die Leute grün angemalt haben
Force Champ
die haben die Leute grün angemalt
die haben die Anzüge grün angesprayt
ein bisschen
einen grünen Look
der ist nicht mit einem Overlay gemacht
sondern die waren wirklich grün
was hältst du von
IT Stellen im öffentlichen Dienst
ich habe da keine persönliche Erfahrung mit
ähm
der einzige den ich kenne
von dem ich weiß
dass er dort drin gearbeitet hat
der fand es kacke
den kennt ihr übrigens auch
ich meine Algorithmen verstehen
der nicht mal Algorithmen verstehen heißt
ich kann es dir nicht sagen
ich habe keinen Bock drauf
weil Kohle nicht so geil
und zweitens
haftet dem ganzen Kram ja immer so ein bisschen
wie soll man sagen
Dienst nach Vorschrift
und kein Bock
bis Frustration an
was man so liest
also eher weniger Bock
die haben sie grün
ja
die haben die Leute grün angemalt
nein nein
die Schauspieler hatten grüne Farbe im Gesicht
die haben die Leute wirklich grün gemacht
die haben sicherlich manches auch mit dem Filter gemacht
aber vieles in Matrix 1
war wirklich grün
beim Aufnehmen das war kein Post Processing
und kein Overlay
was hältst du davon IT Consultant zu werden
nix
als jemand der Wirtschaftswissenschaft
studiert hat
hassen die ITler wirklich so sehr die
das kommt auf den Projektmanager an
das liegt oftmals an den Projektmanagern selbst
mir ist es vollkommen egal
was ein Projektmanager studiert hat
und was der
was der vorher das ist
juckt mich überhaupt nicht
wenn es ein gescheiter Projektmanager ist
ist das ok
wenn er nix geschissen kriegt
ist mir auch egal was der im Vorfeld gelernt hat
das hängt vom Projektmanager ab
ist mir vollkommen egal ob der BWL Zeug
gelernt hat im Vorfeld oder nicht
ich persönlich habe aber den Eindruck
dass besonders
BWL Leute es oft verkacken
das mag aber an meinem Vorurteil
gegenüber BWL Leuten liegen
ich habe übrigens noch
Fun Fact Matrix 1
Helikopter
diese Szene
kennt wahrscheinlich
mehr oder weniger jeder
die Helikopter Szene
wo sie Morpheus da raus ballern
und wusstet ihr
dass
wusstet ihr dass der Hintergrund
in dieser Szene
eine Leinwand ist
die größte Leinwand
die jemals für einen Film hergestellt wurde
Matrix ist eines der wenigen Filme
wo ich in Making-of geguckt habe
es sieht gar nicht so aus
aber der Hintergrund
selbst wenn man es weiß
sieht man das nicht
die haben das ja auch gut
mit dem Wasser gemacht
das ist gemalt der Hintergrund
das ist einfach nur ein Bild
einfach nur ein Bild im Hintergrund
ich habe das offizielle
Making-of geguckt vor einer ganzen Zeit
Teil 2
ich habe zwar alle
außer den allerneuesten Matrix
Film den habe ich nicht geguckt
den will ich auch nicht gucken
ich habe die alte Matrix Trilogie geguckt
aber ganz ehrlich
der erste Teil ist für mich
mit
meinem Lieblingsfilm schlechthin
den kann ich mir immer alle paar Jahre
wieder angucken oder teilweise auch
alle Jahre mal angucken
den Kram danach konntest du knicken
aber Matrix 1 ist eines der
besten Filme die ich kenne
es ist alles also wirklich
ich finde bei Matrix 1
stimmt
passt einfach alles zusammen
die haben
mega geile Effekte für die Zeit
die dadurch das in Matrix 1
erstaunlich wenig CGI drin ist
man denkt das gar nicht so
man denkt sich wenn man sich Matrix 1 anguckt
denkt man es ist alles CGI
nein nein es ist in Matrix 1
vieles wo man denkt es ist CGI ist gar kein CGI
und die Effekte
waren wirklich bahnbrechend nice
aber was das beste war an Matrix 1
die hatten eine wirklich
mitreißende Story dabei
die dich auch
überrascht hat
und es kommt bei mir sehr selten
vor das ein Film fertig ist
und ich denk mir so am Ende
boah das wars jetzt
so
ne wisst ihr wie ich mein so ey
richtig geil
und das kommt bei mir nicht so oft vor wenn ich Filme
geguckt hab aber bei Matrix kam das
vor deswegen ist für mich persönlich Matrix 1
immer noch eines der besten Filme die es gibt
wow Raid
dankeschön
Kokiri 156 Leute
schön das ihr da seid
ja war richtig
also Matrix 1 ist wirklich ohne Mist
immer noch einer meiner absoluten Lieblingsfilme
so
wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben
oh mein Auge
oh fuck alter
du bist ja blind danach
meine Güte
wo sind wir denn eigentlich stehen geblieben
ich hab voll die Übersicht verloren
gerade
keine Ahnung
ja wie dem auch sei
ja
Matrix ist tatsächlich
relativ gut gealtert
ja das stimmt
naja also
habt ihr noch irgendwelche Stellenanzeigen
ansonsten würde ich mal gucken
was uns denn LinkedIn heute
so schönes
presentet
und das würde ich mal angucken
IT System Administrator
let's go
ok
was haben wir denn hier
Engineering the extra
das ist wieder so ein typisches englisches Wort
weil ich das nicht richtig aussprechen kann
Extra
Ordinary also das besonders
außergewöhnliche quasi
ja wenn ihr gute Entwicklerstellen habt schießt los
was
ist hier los
IT Systems Administrator
in Deggendorf
Bavaria
Grüß Gott
oder Servus
ich glaub Grüß Gott sagen die wenigsten in Bayern
auch heute noch aber Servus Servus
geht eigentlich immer Servus find ich auch
das ist so richtig schön universell
ich glaub Servus kannst du hier sagen als
Begrüßung und als Abschied
Leute ich hab zu viele Tabs auf
kann ich zumachen das kann ich
zumachen genau ok
also was wollen die das ist ja auf Englisch
mal hier richtig international alles
also was wollen die da haben
a day in the life
Careers that change lives
jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen
na gut
sie sind in der Medizin und sowas
da kann man das ist eigentlich gar kein schlechter Spruch
ja morgen geht es schlecht zum verabschieden
das stimmt
also so die Aufgaben können enthalten
also
eine
eine weiche Operation
maintainen von
Multi User Computer Systems
ja gut
da würde ich sagen das passt zu einem System
Administrator ziemlich gut das ist
so eigentlich die der Inbegriff
eines IT System Administrators
dass die Systeme laufen
including
coordination ok und man muss sich
mit anderen also man muss sich
übergreifend abstimmen ja das klingt
natürlich auch passend
alleine kannst du das eh nicht alles machen
so man installiert man
betreibt man verwaltet und
wartet Hardware
Software
inklusive
Administrator und Service Accounts
Wartung von Dokumentation
alter das siehst du
die haben ein Stream nicht oft genug geguckt
das sind halt einfach alles Kack Nubs
die wissen nicht wenn man keine Fehler macht
dann muss man auch nichts dokumentieren
das ist
Zero Fault Driven Development
und vor allem
braucht man auch keine Kommentare
und keine Tests
wisst ihr was es für Zeit spart
wenn man keine Kommentare
keine Tests und keine Dokumentation
schreiben muss weil einfach alles funktioniert
das muss
ich brauche irgendwie
wir brauchen da eine coole Abkürzung für
sowas wie ITIL
nur mit Wubblors drinnen
wie das könnte man da machen
ah fällt mir gerade nichts ein
Wubtil
ne keine Ahnung
ok
Performance Tuning
einfach alles richtig machen
ZFDD
das finde ich tatsächlich ganz gut
Zero Fault Driven Development
ok System Performance
Backup Recovery
gut
ist natürlich ganz klassische Administrationssache
ok
Konfigurationschanges
iih da hört schon auf
da hätte ich schon wieder keinen Bock mehr drauf
Interact with Users
NO GOD
NO GOD PLEASE NO
NO
da ist es bei mir schon vorbei
da können sich die IT Systeme selbst administrieren
Interaktion mit Usern
oh
hör mal bloß auf
und anderen Stake
Stake Haltern
ok man ist bei der Auswahl von neuen Produkten
dabei das macht natürlich auch Sinn
Manages
Monitors Policies
ja Monitor
ja das ist so ein 0815 Satz
das ergibt auch Sinn
was
Executes on Programs
and Projects
within a specific
den Satz verstehe ich nicht
Englisch Fail
was wollen die mir sagen
also mit Programme meinen die keine Programme
sondern eher sowas wie Projekte
das verstehe ich auch
man hilft
man unterstützt in Projekten
teamübergreifend quasi
sowas wollen die uns
wahrscheinlich
ne
man unterstützt Projekte
quasi innerhalb einer
Abteilung
oder sowas in der Richtung
was auch immer das heißen soll
Bachelors Degree Required
Bam
als IT System Administrator
What
Server Admin ist eines der sagen wir mal
klassischsten 0815 mäßigsten Jobs
in der Richtung
warum braucht man einen Bachelor dafür
nicht das es in irgendeiner Art und Weise
was bringt weil man einen Bachelor hat dafür
und mal ganz davon abgesehen
sie sagen ja auch 0
zu ihren Systemen
ist es Linux ist es Windows
es ist
man weiß es nicht
das ist eine schlechte Stellenanzeige
also das ist eine wirklich miese
Stellenanzeige
da steht nichts drinne
was irgendwie relevant wäre
außer wirklich
0815 also wenn
Punkt AI meint das das Chat
GPT generiert ist
dann würde ich das auch
sofort glauben
was hältst du von der
die habe ich doch hier schon auf
also hier
die meinst du ja
welche davon
welche
da müssen sich alle angucken
Software Entwickler Software
Development Engineer
Software Developer
guck mal die sind richtig
high IQ die suchen Software Developer
Software Entwickler und Software
Development Engineer
such dir eine raus dann nehme ich die
weil das was ist wo ich wahrscheinlich noch was zu
sagen kann
bei den Entwicklerstellen ist immer
je nachdem
SAP Entwickler
MonkaS
eine Runde ABAP Leute
kann einer von euch ABAP
das ist ein
Web Design Jack
geht klar
auf Xing sind sie am Start
ich mach die Seite mal wieder hässlicher
dafür weniger Flashback mäßig
nicht Spammen Chatge
nicht Spammen
was haben wir denn hier noch
falls ihr was übersehen habt sagt Bescheid
so also ein was
suchen sie ein Site Reliability Engineer
männlich weiß deutsch wie immer
Vollzeit oh da hätte ich schon mal gelitten
willst du deinen Job wegnehmen
wechseln
ich gucke einfach nur
hier gab es doch mal einen Captain ABAP
wirklich
hier hatten wir mal einen Captain Poggers hatten wir mal
und den haben wir auch immer noch
auch wenn er hier nicht Captain Poggers heißt
ok also was haben die hier am Start
bei einem führenden
deutschen Business Software Anbieter
den Betrieb skalierbarer
Cloud Software vorantreiben und gemeinsam wachsen
schnarch
das ist
wir brauchen den Intro Satz
lass mal irgendwas schreiben
skalierbar und führend und
überhaupt aber wenigstens
hey ich find's eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
ich find's gar nicht so schlecht
normalerweise bestehen die Stellenanzeigen
immer aus einer halben Seite
dass sie führend im Bereich XY
sind und einfach super geil
und das
interessiert meistens überhaupt gar keinen
ja denke ich mir auch genau
wenigstens kurz und knapp es ist zwar auch so nicht aber
wenigstens kurz und knapp
oh au
hab ich jetzt gemacht
ich hab meine Nackenstütze jetzt runtergeklappt
die nicht runterklappen sollte
so
also
was diesen Job so besonders macht
ok zeig hier
um den Betrieb von
großen skalierenden Systemen sicherzustellen
wendest du Software Engineering
Principles an
wie allgemein möchten sie die Stelle beschreiben
ja
so allgemein wie geht
um den Betrieb wer schreibt diese
Stellenanzeigen immer Mensch Alter
sagt halt mal ein bisschen was genau
was abgeht
um den Betrieb von großen skalierenden Systemen
sicherzustellen wendest du Software Engineering
Principles an
mach dann
agile
viertel 15 minütige
Mikro Sprints
ach du arbeitest da
ok dann muss ich dann dann ok
dann versuche ich das jetzt mal wirklich
so zu erzählen dass man damit was anfangen
kann alles klar ich dachte du willst dich da bemühen
also
das finde ich persönlich
sehr nicht sagen
ich kann mir vorstellen
was der Hintergedanke ist warum man
das so geschrieben hat
so nach dem Motto dass man nicht jetzt
explizit beispielsweise Scrum
reinschreiben möchte oder sowas in der Richtung
wobei man halt sagen muss wir reden hier von einem
Site Reliability Engineer
wollen die damit vielleicht sagen
dass man
wenn man beispielsweise
Cloud Infrastruktur
verwaltet so Infrastructure
Code mäßig dass man sein Source Code
in Git Repo eincheckt
oder sowas weil
für skalierbare Systeme
verwendet man Software Engineering Principles
meinen die sowas
was ist eigentlich ein Site Reliability
ich kann dir da keine genaue Definition von sagen
das sind meistens Leute
die sich um Cloud Infrastruktur kümmern
und dass das alles möglichst hoch
verfügbar ist und
läuft
es ist das ist eines der neueren
Jobbezeichnungen
ich kann dir keine gescheite Definition zu sagen
ok
aber der Sniper schreibt da schon die meinen das
was ich dachte das sie meinen
aber es ist halt super
interpretationsfähig hier der erste Satz
so wiederkehrende Aufgaben
automatisierst und hältst die Dinge simpel
ich kann nicht lesen und hältst die Dinge
simpel um unsere Release Zyklen
zu verkürzen ja gut da würde ich mal vermuten
das ist jetzt vielleicht eher was
wo ich sagen würde hey automatisieren
vielleicht sucht ihr auch eher so eine Art
DevOps Engineer
aber das ist ja bei Jobbezeichnungen
gerade im Cloud Umfeld
das ist ja eh alles sehr fließend
ob das Ding jetzt ein DevOps Engineer ist
ein Cloud Engineer
ja
letztendlich wichtig ist
was hier unten drinnen steht wie der Titel ist
ist jetzt erstmal zweitrangig
alles sehr fließend
ok aber das versteht man
kümmerst dich um Automatisierung
was ja auch eines der Kernaufgaben ist
in dem Bereich
am besten natürlich wenn du es so hinbaust
dass die Leute die es eigentlich benutzen wollen
selbst machen können
am Ende
ja also wenn du es soweit automatisiert hast
dass wenn ein Entwickler sagt ah ich bräuchte
mal eine Umgebung zum testen
dass er dann einfach nur keine Ahnung
sagen wir mal in irgendeinem Teams Chat oder sowas
was schreibt und dann wird für ihn was gestartet
das ist natürlich dann so die Königsdisziplin
der Automatisierung
als Teil eines Cross Funktionalen Teams
unterstützt du unsere Software Engineers
dabei die Prozesse im Auge zu behalten um
die Qualität unserer Services zu verbessern
ok
das ist halt auch eher so ein Business Satz
da kann man jetzt nicht viel damit anfangen
ehrlich gesagt
ich mein ja du hilfst letztendlich Entwicklern
dass die Sache funktioniert
aber es ist so
möglichst vage
sehr vage alles
du richtest eigenverantwortliche Tests
äh Qualitätssicherung
und produktiv
achso die meinen sowas wie Testumgebung
Integrationsumgebung
das nennt ja eh jeder ein bisschen anders
ja
ich hab schon gehört dass es Test heißt
dass es Dev heißt
dass es Int heißt
das ist Integration das ist QA
das ist Live das ist Prod
da gibts diverse Bezeichnungen
im Prinzip ist es oftmals das gleiche
es gibt was zum Basteln
es gibt was zum Abnehmen zum Testen
und es gibt was zum
Geldverdienen
das ist das wo es Geld verdient wird
gemeinsam mit den Entwicklungsteams
ein und nutzen währenddessen Infrastructure
das find ich gut dass ihr das reinschreibt
das ist zum Beispiel so ein Buzzword
wenn ihr für die anderen Punkte
auch noch irgendwelche Begriffe habt
die ein bisschen konkreter sind
fänd ich sinnvoll das reinzuschreiben
weil das ist super vage
und das find ich auch super vage
also
was spricht dagegen wenn man tatsächlich
erwähnt dass es um Ansible Terraform
geht oder vielleicht weiß ich was ihr benutzt
Github Gitlab ähm...
Bucket oder was auch immer
ja dann vielleicht noch irgendwie welches
die ICT System
weil das ist immer schwierig so
so Universal Dinger
das ist auch schwierig sich da drauf zu bewerben
wenn da nichts wirklich handfestes drinsteht
da kriegst du dann solche Bewerbungen
wie mit großem Interesse
bla bla bla bla bla
das langweiligste Intro aller Zeiten
ähm...
ich bin ein großer Fan von
skalierenden Systemen
und ich wende sicher
mir Engineering Principles an
mit so einer Bewerbung hast du ja im Endeffekt
von so einer Bewerbung hast du ja im Endeffekt dann auch nichts
kannst du höchstens hoffen das im
Lebenslauf irgendwas steht wo du dann reininterpretieren
kannst was der jetzt damit
meinte falls er es überhaupt selber weiß
so
warum ausgerechnet du diesen Job
warum ausgerechnet du zu diesem Job passt
ok jetzt wird's
ok es wird jetzt doch ein bisschen konkreter
du hast bereits Erfahrung mit großen IT Infrastrukturen
im Betrieb komplex verteilte Systeme
AWS Microsoft Azure
ja das ist doch schon mal eine ganze Ecke
konkreter
ganz ehrlich das hätte man sich fast sparen können
hier oben
das ist jetzt da weißt du schon mal ein bisschen
was Sache ist
ich persönlich bin ja Fan von
wenn man vielleicht
noch
bin ja Fan von
wenn man vielleicht noch ein bisschen konkreter genau wüsste
was da eingesetzt wird
ist es noch ein oller Jenkins
ist es Github Actions
ist es GitLab CI
was auch immer
finde ich persönlich ganz spannend
finde ich auch bei Bewerben nicht uninteressant
weil es könnte ja durchaus was sein dass es
was ist wo ich mich schon mit beschäftigt
hab und was ist wo ich besonders Bock drauf hab
das zu benutzen
es gibt ja nochmal Bonus
also an sich finde ich es nicht verkehrt
mal so ein paar
eingesetzte
Tools zu droppen
Service Level Indicators
und Service Level Objectives
sind keine
Fremdwörter für dich
sondern die Grundlage deiner Arbeit
ich muss dir ehrlich sagen
ich hab keine Ahnung
was das ist
ich kann es mir
ich kann das schon rein interpretieren
ja
und wahrscheinlich liege ich damit auch gar nicht so falsch
aber aus dem Stehkraft wüsste ich eigentlich keine Ahnung
ich gehe davon aus das damit gemeint ist
du hast verschiedene Services die nicht alle gleich wichtig sind
das ist wahrscheinlich das was man damit sagen will
du hast verschiedene Services
die sind unterschiedlich wichtig
die sind dann durchnummeriert nach keine Ahnung
ABC 123 oder Stufe sowieso
macht ja auch jeder ein bisschen anders
und dann gibt es verschiedene
Anforderungen
wo definiert wird was beispielsweise
ein Stufe 2 Service ist
so
also ich gehe davon aus das es Service Level gibt
und hier wird dann definiert was dieses
Service Level genau bedeutet das kann ich rein
interpretieren
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung ob das Industrieweite
Standardbegriffe sind oder nicht
mir sagen sie nix
das heißt aber nix ich mein ich weiß auch nicht alles
aber ich mein ich kann zumindest halbwegs rein interpretieren
was damit gemeint ist
mit deiner analytischen Art
kannst du sowohl Schwachstellen im Systembetrieb
finden als auch Lösungen sie in die Hand haben
unter Systemverfahren ok
du prägst mit deinen Ideen und Impulsen unsere Technologien
es wäre halt ein bisschen spannend
zu wissen was das welche Technologien
es eigentlich sind ja
denn du weißt das kontinuierlich
Verbesserungen und Veränderungen zum Arbeitsleben dazugehört
durch deine
kommunikative Art und deine Softwaretechnische
Denkweise
wie auch immer das gemeint ist förderst du den
Austausch zwischen Operations und Entwicklung
und ich glaube ihr wollt eher
einen DevOps Engineer haben als einen Site Reliability
Engineer oder gerade beim
letzten Satz finde ich würde das
thematisch doch dann besser passen
und
vor allem weil es hier auch um
Automatisierung und so was
geht das klingt für mich eher nach einem
DevOps Engineer was ihr sucht
aber letztendlich Jobbezeichnung Schall
und Rauch
macht eh jeder wie er will und trägst Impulse
und Ideen weiter sodass unsere Technologien
stetig optimiert werden
ah ja
ist keine schlechte Stellenanzeige
für mich
für meinen Geschmack ein bisschen wenig Details
weil außer das ihr AWS
und Azure vielleicht verwendet
ist jetzt da nicht so viel greifbares
drin ehrlich gesagt
also ich würde mich nicht drauf bewerben
weil ich der Meinung wäre
das und das passt nicht so richtig
vom Titel und das was man macht
und weil ich mir überhaupt nicht
vorstellen könnte
was ihr eigentlich genau
an Skills braucht
ich hab das jetzt alles nur geraten
und ich hatte recht damit zum größten Teil anscheinend
aber es wäre ja nice wenn man das wüsste
aber ansonsten
habe ich schon deutlich
abschreckenderes gesehen
das geht schon klar
ok
ach ja
eine Sache auch noch
was ich auf jeden Fall noch einschreiben würde
wenn es bei euch die Möglichkeit gibt
zu mobilem Arbeiten
oder Homeoffice
schreibt das unbedingt rein
steht im Weißen echt wo
wo
oben
ich sehe hier nichts
im Titel
im Titel steht Vollzeit
ach da
ok das liegt an mir
normalerweise sieht die Webseite so aus
und da kann man das auch erkennen
Mobile Office und Standorteinerwahl
ohne Mist
trotzdem
schreibt das doch irgendwie rein
die Leute sehen es nicht
die sind so dumm wie ich
und checken nicht das da oben steht
wenn ihr das bei euch
dreimal bitte anfragen
und dreifachem Durchschlag beim Chef möglich ist
man lasst es raus
weil es macht ja keinen Sinn die Leute mit was zu locken
im Endeffekt was nicht stattfindet
aber wenn das bei euch wirklich möglich ist
im größeren Stil
reitet da ruhig ein bisschen drauf rum in dem Text
weil das ist das was die Leute unter anderem auch überzeugt
dahin zu gehen
ja und vielleicht der ein oder andere Satz
zur Kohle die man verdienen kann
zumindest so
ja
beziehungsweise wäre vielleicht auch nicht verkehrt
so fertig
next
was haben wir denn hier
was ist denn das für eine Adresse
topconw1myworkdayjobs.com
ok das ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine
Subdomain für irgendwie verschiedene
Loadbalancer Server
wo man rauskommt bei denen
also immer
aber gleich
darfst du ein bisschen Eigenwerbung machen
ja darfst du machen
wir haben gar nicht mal so viel Zeit heute
warum ist denn schon wieder
da fuck
Leute warum ist denn schon wieder fast 22 Uhr
was ist denn da los
was haben wir denn gemacht
eine Stunde 40 Minuten lang
ich habe wahrscheinlich wieder sinnloses Zeug erzählt
was nichts mit dem Thema zu tun hat
ok Chat
ich habe eine Frage
die drei Stellenanzeigen
die wir noch offen haben
wollt ihr euch da bewerben
die die sie gepostet haben?
oder
sind die von der Firma wo ihr arbeitet
weil dann würde ich tatsächlich jetzt mal mit der anfangen
von Shagger
wenn wir schon beim Thema Eigenwerbung
jetzt gehts los
ich kann mir das gar nicht mal heute alles angucken
aber es geht ja nicht verloren
ich muss mal ein paar Videos schließen Leute
das haben wir bestimmt schon geguckt
das
weiß ich nicht
warum mein Eis ist irgendwas nass
das wollen wir gucken jetzt auch nicht mehr
das werden wir auch nicht gucken
das soll ich
ok
ok da Shagger
also IT Administrator Systemadministrator
MWD in München
Festanstelle Vollzeit München
alles klar
deine Aufgaben lets go
als IT Administrator
wisst ihr was ich gleich schon mal gut finde
an der Stellenanzeige
ich habe zwar keine Ahnung
was
Sina Force macht
aber
ich finde schon mal gut das es nicht los geht mit
wir sind Sina Force
der führende Anbieter
im Bereich XY
und unser Ziel ist ein
super krass agiles Kreiselcrime Mindset
und deswegen sind wir die geilsten
überhaupt
ich bin froh dass sie den Kram einfach weggelassen haben
äh was
habe ich dazu
mich geäußert im Stream
ich weiß gar nicht was das ist
vielleicht dass sie einen neuen Font haben
ach Office ja
nicht mehr Calibri ok ich bin
Arial Enjoyer
Verdana und Arial
aber ich verwende eh kein Office insofern auch das nicht mehr
ja geklaut
für mich ist auch wichtig was die Firma macht
aber mich nervt das immer
wenn in den Stellenanzeigen ein halber
Roman drüber steht was das ist
wenn mir die Stellenanzeige gefällt
dann gehe ich auf die Webseite von denen und guck mir an was die treiben
und fertig
ich finde das Muster gar nicht drin ist
also mich nervt das immer
wenn da ein halber Roman drin steht
wie geil die jeweilige Firma ist
das finde ich schon mal gut
aber siehste mal Chat so unterschiedlich können die Ansichten sein
also deine Aufgaben als IT Administrator
Systemadministrator erwartet dich
bei Synophons eine ganze Reihe
an spannenden Aufgaben und vielfältigen Herausforderungen
Remote und vor Ort Betreuung von Kunden
und deren
Client und Server Infrastruktur
da hätte ich ja persönlich schon mal gar keinen Bock drauf
weil
also
überhaupt Kundenbetreuung hätte ich keinen Bock drauf
und vor Ort noch weniger
aber ihr sucht halt was ihr sucht
nur weil ich da keinen Bock drauf habe
heißt ja nicht das ihr das nicht braucht
ihr sucht halt jemanden
also ich hätte da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
aber gut das ist halt das
was gesucht wird
und man versteht wenigstens was gesucht wird
wobei man sagen muss
Client und Server Infrastruktur zusammen ist
vielleicht auch ein bisschen merkwürdig
weil ist es nicht eigentlich so
ist es nicht eigentlich eher so dass
ja gut da geht es wahrscheinlich um kleinere Läden
aber ich hätte jetzt eher vermutet
dass man sich vielleicht um
ja vor Ort um
irgendwie Anwendungen die man verkauft hat
kümmert oder
irgendwelche Serversachen aber dann gleich noch
die Clients mit da haben die doch meistens selbst Leute für
es sei denn man betreut die
man betreut die komplett
Beratung unserer Bestands und möglichen Neukunden
Erstellung von maßgeschneiderten IT Lösungen
auf die jeweiligen Kundenbedürfnisse
eigenverantwortliche Entwicklung von Projekten
ach ab nicht Entwicklung
Abwicklung von Projekten
ja so hätte ich das auch interpretiert
ok dein Profil
also ich muss sagen
das ist alles
alles gesamt sehr
vage ich wüsste nicht
was auf mich zukommt
aber wahrscheinlich ist das schwierige
daran es so
zu beschreiben
also wahrscheinlich geht es tatsächlich nicht besser
zu beschreiben weil es irgendwelche Custom
Sachen sind je nach Kunde unterschiedlich
und
das ist halt schwierig
also ich verstehe warum man es so schreibt
aber ich kann mir da
wenig darunter vorstellen was konkret denn da jetzt
eigentlich gemacht wird
ist es Windows eher ist es eher Linux
ist es Cloud Infrastruktur
hauptsächlich nur bei denen
vor Ort
verkauft ihr Software
oder nicht
also
ja keine Ahnung also das
finde ich ist irgendwie so
genau dein Profil
erfolgreich abgeschlossene
Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker im Studium
oder vergleichbare
mehrjährige Berufserfahrung ok
wenn ihr mehrjährige
Berufserfahrung wollt je nachdem wie viel
mehrjährige ist sucht ihr vielleicht nicht sogar
ein Senior Erfahrung im
Umgang mit Microsoft ach
so ok
ich habe nichts gesagt
dann ist das vollkommen in Ordnung
ich hätte weiterlesen müssen
dann geht das natürlich klar
hier oben ist so abstrakt
was man halt so allgemein macht
ohne jetzt konkret
um was es technisch geht
und jetzt kommt ne dann geht das dann geht das klar alles
ähm
Erfahrungen im Umgang mit Microsoft
da wäre ich schon raus
an der Stelle
Erfahrungen mit Microsoft Windows Server Active Directory
Exchange oder Linux Servern
ich kann es nur nochmal sagen
es ist sehr
schwierig Leute zu finden
die beides können
also ich kenne Leute
die haben mit Windows angefangen
haben sich dann mit Linux auseinandergesetzt
und haben noch historische Windows
Kenntnisse umgedreht
fällt mir gar keiner ein der mit Linux
angefangen hat und jetzt hauptsächlich
Windows Server macht aber jemand der
tiefgreifende Kenntnisse
aktuelle Kenntnisse in beidem hat
ist enorm schwierig zu finden
also ich meine
ich könnte in Windows auch diesen komischen Assistent
durchklicken ach das ist mit
siehst du das hätte ich mit dem oder gar nicht so rein
interpretiert
ich hätte jetzt eher gesagt so ah ja gut
das kommt da alles auf mich zu
gute Kenntnisse in allen
ja gut
jetzt kommt es ja da nochmal
also muss kannst du
gute Kenntnisse in allen Microsoft und Mac
kleinen Betriebssystemen
das ist ja wirklich
alles oder
Linux Windows Mac
was erinnerst du dich an das PR
Review
was du Onstream gemacht hast mittlerweile habe ich
einen nice Krypto Job gelandet
dunkel ganz
dunkel ich weiß gar nicht mal um was es da
ging jetzt wo du schreibst
verstehe ich wie er das meint mit dem oder
das würde ich irgendwie anders
schreiben dass den Leuten klar ist
dass ihr nicht jemand wollt der Ahnung von
Windows Linux und Mac hat
aber ohne in Ermangelung
eines besseren Vorschlags
gute Kenntnisse im Bereich Server Virtualisierung
vor allem wie es wäre ja das ist
oder das
das könnt ihr so nicht schreiben also
ich glaube jeder der das liest
interpretiert rein ihr wollt das alles haben
und denkt sich dann alter ist das
übertrieben ich kann mich doch nicht mit
allen Betriebssystemen und allen
Virtualisierungstechnologien auf dem Markt auskennen
wollt ihr vielleicht
mehrere Leute
haben wollt ihr vielleicht
einen Windows Administrator
haben und einen Linux Administrator
also vielleicht sollte man
vielleicht könnte man da zwei Stellenanzeigen draus machen
was dann ein bisschen
spezifischer ist
weil wie gesagt wenn ich mir das angucken würde
würde ich mir denken so boah alter
ich weiß nicht
oder explizit reinschreiben
dass man Erfahrung
aus dem Bereich nur sucht oder
ich weiß nicht mir fällt gerade nichts
gescheites ein aber
wie gesagt für mich liest sich das so
als wollt ihr einfach alles
gute Kenntnisse von Netzwerken und Firewalls
ja gut das passt ja
bei einem Admin gute Kenntnisse
sind VPN Warnanbindung
da werden die Details
jetzt auch ein bisschen interessant
habt ihr irgendwo ein Glasfaserkabel
bei euch im Keller rauskommen oder
oder
geht es da drum bei Endkunden irgendwie
DSL anzuschließen
Kenntnisse in gängigen Backup Software wie
VM Backup Replication Affinität in
IT Security Erfahrung im Cloud
Bereich unter anderem Microsoft Azure
ok ok Bereitschaft zur
fortlaufenden Weiterbildung Besuch von
internen externen Fortbildungsverein
du bist kreativ
also ganz ehrlich
ich glaube ihr meint das nicht so
aber
die
Stellenanzeige ist ja das erste wie die Leute
mit euch in Kontakt kommen
umgedreht genauso wie ihr das erste
mal mit den Leuten halt quasi mit
dem Anschreiben in Kontakt kommt
Gamepad danke für den Sub
für mich liest sich die Stellenanzeige so
als wollt ihr einen Linux Admin
einen Windows Admin und einen Netzwerktechniker
in einem haben plus eventuell noch
ein bisschen Cloud Architektur
und das ist halt einfach übertrieben
und es gibt auch kein rundes Bild
vielleicht sollte man das aufsplitten
dann
bekommt ihr vielleicht nicht für jede Stelle
äh massig Bewerbung
aber
ihr findet vielleicht einen
mit einem guten Profil der dann auf das
passt was Sinn ergibt
zusammen also ich finde das ist
zu viel warum wir
Freiraum Atmosphäre Sicherheit
...
moderner Arbeitsplatz
Home Office oft das ist gut
dass es drinnen steht
Perspektive
Einarbeitung
ok
also muss ich ehrlich sagen mich spricht die Stellenanzeige
nicht an ich weiß du hast sie
nicht geschrieben ich sag's dir mal nur
falls du da irgendwie
an deine Personalabteilung
was weitergeben
möchtest also ich finde das ist zu viel
auf einmal was da drinnen steht
sollte man das aufsplitten
wenn man nämlich wirklich Leute sucht die sich auskennen
mit KVM Netzwerk
Linux sollte man eine Stellenanzeige
machen wenn man Leute sucht die sich mit
ähm Azure Office
Windows Server auskennen
sollte man eine eigene Stelle ausmachen vielleicht wollt ihr auch jemand
der sich mit vielleicht sollte man da wirklich drei verschiedene
Stellen draus machen ihr werdet
vielleicht am Ende nicht alle besetzt bekommen aber bekommt
vielleicht so passendere Bewerbung
und wie viel Kohle man verdient wäre auch nicht
schlecht aber da schreiben wir die wenigsten rein
wer wollte noch Eigenwerbung machen
eben schon wieder
habe ich schon wieder übersehen Agineo
ach ne das war das was ich gerade geschlossen
sag mal haben die zwei einfach ein super ähnliches
Logo gehabt ach so und die sind
beide grün ja die haben kein ähnliches
Logo die waren einfach noch beide grün
ja übrigens Versuchs der Personalabteilung
schonend beizubringen
ich weiß nicht wie die drauf sind
manche
manche mögen das nicht so habe ich schon
gemerkt wenn man
ihnen da versucht rein zu
reden wobei ich eigentlich
echter Meinung bin dass alle Seiten
immer froh sein können
wenn diejenigen die es im
Endeffekt dann auch wirklich betrifft
beziehungsweise diejenigen die man schon im Unternehmen
hat die man quasi mit sowas
ansprechen möchte potenziell
also falls sie noch nicht da wären
zu sowas interviewt
ich weiß nicht wie die bei euch drauf sind
ok das ist das letzte was wir heute machen
dann muss ich ins Bett wir sind jetzt bei
Agineo
die halten ihre
Selbstbeweihräucherung auch kurz und knackig
das finde ich gut
sie zählen zu den führenden Anbietern
wer zählt nicht zu den führenden Anbietern
in solchen
in solchen Stellenanzeigen
Intro Texten
gefühlt ist jeder führende
Anbieter in irgendeinem Bereich
gibt es Stellenanzeigen mit so einem Text
die nicht anfangen mit das sie führend sind
in irgendeinem Bereich
zählen zu den führenden Anbietern für IT Management
und Betriebslösung im deutschsprachigen Raum
wir suchen zurzeit ok
Javascript Anwendungsentwickler im ServiceNow
MonkaS
damit muss ich bearbeiten
ich weiß aber nicht wie das entwicklungstechnisch aussieht
das System wirkt allerdings
schon etwas
1995 mäßig
so und so sieht es auch aus
also was wollen die haben
Javascript Entwickler
zu ihren Aufgaben
als Anwendungsentwickler gehören
Unterstützung unserer Projektteams
bei internationalen Enterprise Kunden
ok
Spezifikation
ich habe jetzt gelernt ich halte jetzt erstmal die Klappe
dazu und gucke was unten drunter kommt
bevor ich mich jetzt da wieder auslasse
dass es zu unspezifisch ist
ok Spezifikation
Abschätzung von Kundenanforderungen
ok ja gut
das ist wichtig als Anwendungsentwickler
nennt sich neudeutsch
User Stories sowas
und wenn man ganz cool ist
schreibt man User Stories
auch so aus User Sicht
ich persönlich finde das komplett unsinnig
aber kennt ihr diese Sachen mit
ähm
ich als User
möchte beim anmelden im System
eine
möglichst klares
Dashboard angezeigt bekommen
damit ich meine Aufgaben sofort
sehen kann
kennt ihr das
also
ich weiß nicht genau wo dieser Trend
herkommt
ich finde es komplett unsinnig
das so zu schreiben
weil wo ist der Unterschied
ob ich das so aus Fake User Sicht
schreibe oder einfach
reinschreibe ok wir brauchen
ein ordentlich strukturiertes Dashboard
mit den und den Punkten
ok aber gut
Abschätzung Kundenanforderungen
das ist wichtig als Anwendungsentwickler
sehe ich auch so
Entwicklung mit Javascript und HTML
innerhalb eines modernen
SARS Frameworks
ServiceNow
schon falsch in einer User Story kann man keine
Anwendung haben
ich schreibe sowas nie selbst
ich drück mich da immer vor
bis es irgendjemand anderes schreibt
Schnittstellenentwicklung
ja
Webser... Soap
oh
NO GOD
PLEASE NO
NO
NOOOOOO
naja gut
es ist genau so hätte ich so
ServiceNow eingeschätzt
das ist noch Soap an vielen Stellen
wobei das nichts ist
gegen dieses
was war das
was hatte ich bei der alten Firma
wie hieß dieses System
das war kein Ticketsystem
das ich API technisch ansprechen wollte
das war so ein
Knowledge Base System
ähm
oh fuck wie hieß das
das hatte am Anfang noch eine Flash Oberfläche
ich hab vergessen wie das heißt
ich ich
ich hab es euch schon mal erzählt
das war
das war so
so shit
zumindest die hatten API
abfragen
das war JSON
mit Embedded XML
das es funktioniert hat
du hast dann
also wenn ihr euch fragt wie sowas aussieht
du hattest dann zum Beispiel so
JSON Request
da stand dann sowas hier drinnen
wie zum Beispiel keine Ahnung
Method Login
ich denk mir jetzt random einfach irgendwas aus
so und dann gab es Filter
und da stand dann drinnen
ähm
Search
TechW
sowas hatten die da
nur deutlich ausführlicher
du hattest quasi
XML Embedded in JSON
drinnen
wie hieß denn das
ich hab da geflucht drüber
ah ich weiß wieder wie das hieß
ich weiß wieder wie das hieß
FNT hieß das
FNT commands genau
ja unter anderem so
sieht das aus
da weißt du
Leute ihr wisst Bescheid
wenn ihr sowas seht solche Oberflächen schon
wisst ihr Bescheid
ja das hat auch ein Plugin für Rack Anzeigen
das war das
das ist das war wirklich eines der
nervigsten Knowledge Base
so das war kein wirkliches
Knowledge Base das war Knowledge Base
und und
so CMDB in einem
ganz grausam
ganz grausames Ding alter
super grausam
hyper grausam
war das
die wissen schon warum man keine Screenshots
auf der Webseite findet dazu
wisst ihr es gibt
echt ein Auswahlkriterium
zeigt der Software Anbieter keine Screenshots
auf ihrer Seite
sondern nur irgendwelche super tollen
Dinger die irgendwelche Management BWL
Leute beeindrucken sollen dann ist es
in der Regel einfach Scheiße
sag nicht das ist
keine also ich sag jetzt nicht
explizit das FNT Scheiße ist
sondern meine Erfahrung nach
ist Software die keine
Screenshots zeigt und keine
ja so sieht es aus wenn man es benutzt
meistens Scheiße
ok gucken wir uns aber die Stellenanzeige
ach so wie sieht es eigentlich bei Tracks Tools aus?
aha
Microsoft Teams ist oben
Nodes ist gar nicht mehr so weit oben
Leute ok
die Seite gibt es auch schon seit 20 Jahren
ok Durchführung von
Kundenterminen
da würde ich jetzt sagen
klingt jetzt erstmal nicht so sehr nach einem primären
Ding von einem Anwendungsentwickler aber wenn es in dem Fall so ist
dann ist es so
hätte ich keinen Bock drauf
Sie fühlen sich von folgendem Profil angesprochen
abgeschlossenes Informatikstudium
alternativ aber ok
immer das gleiche
fundierte Programmierkenntnisse in Javascript
Javascript
Kenntnisse allgemeiner aktueller Webtechnologien
ja
sollte man als Javascriptentwickler schon
mitbringen Datenbank SQL Kenntnisse
englische
Wort und Schrift Teamfähigkeit Zielgerichte
strukturierte Selbstständige Arbeitsweise
Bereitschaft zur Reisetätigkeit
boah das schreckt
viele Leute ab das kann ich euch gleich schon sagen
hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf
sicheres und
pflegt es auf
Moment
bist du hier Anwendungsentwickler
oder
ich vermute
du bist Anwendungsentwickler der mitgenommen wird
zu irgendwelchen Verkaufsveranstaltungen
kann das sein
wer hat das gepostet
Dani
hast du das gepostet
irgendjemand
Frage an denjenigen der das gepostet hat
das sind
Leute die
den Entwickler mitnehmen zu irgendwelchen Verkaufsveranstaltungen oder
so nach dem Motto
wie in diesem
The Expert Video
oder wie das hieß
jaja
jetzt verstehe ich was ihr vor habt
ok
ihr braucht jemand der den Kram programmieren kann
der das aber auch
naja verkaufen ist das falsche Wort
der zumindest die Leute nicht davon
abschreckt es zu kaufen
und dabei ist wenn eure Sales Leute
denen irgendwelche wirren Dinger
verkaufen
ok
da braucht ihr den passenden Typ für
verstehe
also ich habe jetzt hier nichts
zum Thema Homeoffice gelesen
ja
finde ich gut das es drinsteht
sofern es auch ernst gemeint ist
ansonsten
für meinen Geschmack tatsächlich
ein bisschen wenig
Details mein Datenbank SQL
Kenntnisse
super allgemein welche Datenbanken wären
noch interessant ok wahrscheinlich ServiceNow
die benutzen bestimmt eine eigene
weil
weil halt
aber so ein bisschen mehr was eigentlich
genau und JavaScript also sprich
ja gut wahrscheinlich alles im ServiceNow
Kontext also sprich da kannst du da kommst du halt mit
View und React nicht weit du brauchst halt
ServiceNow ja weiß nicht ob es Sinn macht
da mehr technische Details reinzuschreiben
wenn es halt alles eben ServiceNow ist dann ist es
ServiceNow und was vielleicht nicht
verkehrt wäre
wenn man zumindest mal ein paar
moderne Sachen droppen könnte
ja wie zum Beispiel
das ihr Git und GitLab verwendet
oder Git und
jeder verwendet heutzutage Git
aber es ist vielleicht nicht schlecht
es reinzuschreiben weil es gibt ja auch welche
die fuddeln heute noch
mit alternativen Sachen rum und da hätte ich
als Entwickler schon mal gar keinen Bock drauf
was ist mit ServiceNow ist eine
Software unter anderem so für Helpdesk Sachen
und sowas also so ein paar
so ein paar
Technikbegriffe würde ich rein
droppen das man sieht das es sich hier
wirklich um sag mal moderne
Softwareentwicklung handelt
ob es modern ist mit SOAP und ServiceNow
vom Produkt her sei mal hingestellt
aber es gibt ja einen Unterschied einmal
für das Produkt wofür man entwickelt und
wie man entwickelt und wenn
man da zumindest mal erwähnt das man Git als
Sourcing
Sourceverwaltung verwendet oder das man
ähm CICD
mit GitHub Actions macht
oder mit GitLab ist ja
das finde ich nicht verkehrt
fände ich nicht schlecht
und ich glaube das würde auch ein paar Leute
mehr davon überzeugen das es halt
ein moderner Laden ist
der halt ServiceNow Sachen entwickelt
also ein paar Technik Sachen hier drinnen droppen
fände ich persönlich nicht verkehrt
so
so sieht es aus Leute ich muss jetzt ins Bett
gibst du weiter erzähl mal
was ihr gesagt habt
ihr könnt euch übrigens bei mir
selbstverständlich auch noch weiteres
Consulting zu Stellenanzeigen einkaufen
wenn ihr wollt also falls jetzt irgendjemand sagt
Max ich würde gerne
das du ausführlich unsere
Stellenanzeigen analysierst
und das ganze
schriftlich uns zukommen lässt
und das auch noch ausführlicher erklärst
und wir wollen unbedingt
auf deine Expertise zurückgreifen
da könnt ihr mir eine E-Mail an meine
Business Adresse schreiben und das können wir machen
habe ich noch nie gemacht aber wenn einer
wirklich das Bedürfnis dazu hatte
ich mach das
dann werde ich Stellenanzeigen Review
Consultant
aber jetzt mal ernsthaft ich denke
ich kann dazu wirklich
aus Sicht
eines
potenziellen Bewerbers ganz gut was
zu sagen
weil ich bin ja oftmals also ich bin ja bei den
Stellenanzeigen die wir uns angucken oftmals einer
der Kandidaten die man potenziell mit sowas
ansprechen will auch wenn ich aktuell keinen Job
suche aber ich kann dir sofort sagen
ob mich was anspricht oder nicht
so Leute ich gehe jetzt ins Bett
wir hören uns morgen oder die Tage
bis dann machts gut see you
achso Business E-Mail Adresse findet ihr auf dem Channel
steht da ganz kurz drauf falls wirklich irgendjemand will
also bis dann machts gut see you